yeah I have Ali Resa with me Ali Resa
welcome to the show let's check what
happened in this game I think you came
very close at one point probably to
winning I don't know what was your
feeling during the game yeah I think it
should have been I think much better at
least so I think there was a first
critical moment you played this Knight
G5 and after H6 you came back probably I
thought that you had some ideas maybe to
play after H6 I don't know Knight of
seven or yeah I saw this line and I
didn't believe I have I'm playing for
anything mhm I so after Queen H4 I
couldn't find anything yeah so I just
went back to play game so probably
doesn't matter yesterday yeah it's a
very typical London
position um here we were playing normal
moves and I think he was too slow he
should have gone f65 faster or F5 F4 mhm
so here he played like this I F like I
have good position after
H4 but yeah he played rookie a
H5 takes Bishop
B1 this is very good position because
his King is very weak and I have always
Queen C2 so so you you would provoke F5
so later right mm yeah Queen I think
here I came closest to
winning but I couldn't find the mate the
winning oh yeah I
missed I missed Bishop F five here ah
Bishop F5 yes yeah I missed this thanes
takes and if Queen Rook A7 yes and if
Knight yeah takes
takes oh yeah and in the end you yeah
this is very good yeah so where did you
stop calculating at which point well you
didn't see que I didn't see Bishop
Bishop F5 I see but still this what is
happening
G6 takes okay this is me
yeah I missed Bishop of five okay but
there were also some other moments let's
let's get let's check I me the game was
long with so many opportunities for both
F5 became a little bit tricky somewhere
here yeah I
couldn't yeah I couldn't find the good
moves yeah but I think qu2 was logical
let's not check that much the engine I
mean which other moves like we need to
you allowed all this Rook G2 yeah I said
I have
KN H4 right did you check the move KN H4
yeah I was yeah I checked KN H4 briefly
and so what what did you calculate here
like or you didn't like this Rook G1
Rook E1 I calculated things like mhm I
first of all always Bishop B5 check was
in my mind ah Bish that's why you played
Bishop D only move wow H so what happens
if you if you take C4 yeah I missed C4
because takes takes this this I said I'm
losing or or it's dangerous this I I
refuseed oh but this is clever I could
go C4 ah C4 here yeah because I will not
allow the and queen yes yeah Queen is
not on B5 yes wow yeah these are missed
okay but it's it's hard also to Queen H6
King of7 check and then I take ah and
you take after yes those still not easy
no nothing is easier it seems like in
this
game yeah here you found see it only Mo
mhm yeah and then I felt like he could
play for advant yeah he's minus one yeah
he would you started to feel that is
getting better it's getting really out
of hand here but um I couldn't find
97 in this moments let's say when you
start feeling this like what do what do
you tell to yourself like okay like just
calm down you know come back to the game
what yeah I just wanted to bail out
somehow but yeah this move after I'm
very
because I exchanged one pair of rook and
then I could defend somehow but with two
Rooks yeah this is
annoying yeah but still I have chances
to hold so dra was good result for him I
think at the end maybe also for both I
me it's just crazy I mean do you have
this eager to win the game in this
tournament like what's happening with
you watching all those draws around you
and in your games yeah it's
very um it's not good I'm making all
these drugs I normally don't make these
drugs I know yes of course you're you're
also a fighter yes but it's at the end
all getting drugs I don't know what but
I was winning this game so it's good
start I think and absolutely and I wish
you all the best in the next rounds ala
thank you for coming and sharing your
thoughts we're going to back to the
studio to Yer and Jo and Peter thank you
ala thank you Anastasia